get it back here comes lamela ball with  his hair on fire  [Applause]  a windmill  [Applause]  cody starts to the vacuum  [Applause]  [Music]  oh  gonna play small milwaukee has five  reserves  oh my goodness  [Applause]  miles made four straight threes taylor  into the game last night  irving upset didn't get the call oh  [Applause]  he's falling out of bounds and threw a  beautiful pass to devante  oh my goodness didn't see that coming  deep yeah get it back here comes lamela  paul with his hair on fire  [Applause]  a windmill don't let the paint dry  and the lead is 15 and the hornets have  it back look at this  yes oh the play of the night  terry finds miles in the room rozier  cody zeller offensive rebound  bridges oh my god  what up it's your boy adam lefkow do you  like that content i know you like that  content hit subscribe  for more of it from bleacher report